I keep getting questions in all my
recent videos so I'm gonna make a video
about my thoughts on this subject this
will contain spoilers and speculation
based on the plot leaked for season
seven that surfaced on reddit the leak
may be real or it may be partially based
on fact
but until season 7 airs we won't know
for sure if you don't want things to be
potentially ruined for you then please
stop watching everyone else stick around
till the end to find out about my
current book giveaway and how to enter
to win that out of the way let's get
into it
a few weeks back the poster who has
since deleted their account posted
information on the free folk subreddit
claiming to know the plot for season 7
this has brought up a lot of questions
about the leaks legitimacy since things
like this have happened in the past what
makes it more complicated is that
several things that the user a way for
the lads posted have been backed up with
the filming location spoilers I've
talked about in all my season 7 spoiler
videos my personal feelings about this
is the leak will not turn out to be 100%
accurate I won't get into all the
details about everything that it says in
this video but there are a lot of things
that would be hard to swallow if they
turned out to be true the main thing I'm
going to talk about here is what people
keep asking about and that's
specifically about Viserion being killed
and taking as the night Kings mount I
guess it's important to say in general
I'm not a fan of leaks and I'm not
promoting the idea that this is a good
thing I like the set spoilers because we
can have some fun speculating about what
the things we see might mean later
having an entire story handed to us
totally ruins the fun but alas the news
is out there so how likely is it that
this part is true first when talking
about what happens in the show keep in
mind that logic won't always win the day
I'm not a show hater and can get can
forgive more than some book lovers but
some of the things they do just don't
make sense
related to the world the show is based
on so any argument that comes from that
thinking isn't accepting the situation
as far as what's written in the lore in
history there is no historical evidence
that a dragon was ever
as white the others or White Walkers do
reanimate animals though we've seen them
on undead horses in the show and there's
also references them to raising snow
bears and stuff like that even though
there is no evidence for it it's easy to
explain this one away the White Walkers
have lived north of the wall for the
last eight thousand years which means as
far as we know they never really
actually encountered a dragon the last
time they came South was before the wall
was built there was exactly zero dragons
in Westeros at that time later during
the Targaryen reign which brought you
know those dragons to Westeros from
Essos
the Dragons stayed in the South far away
from the wall there are a couple
examples were dragons traveled north
most notably when King Joe Harris the
first and good Queen Allison visited the
wall they came there with six of their
dragons and half of their court and
Alassane was so impressed with the
Nights Watch that she talked to Joe
Harrison to giving them the new gift
obviously none of their dragons style
why they were there though and certainly
none of them died north of the wall so
even though there's not historical
evidence for it there isn't any
historical evidence against it either /
the leak this all happens because
Vissarion is killed by the night king
could that happen
short answer here is yes it seems
unlikely to me but the night king is a
supernatural beast really we don't have
any reason to say he couldn't do this my
silly logic tells me that the dragon
would be flying and spitting fire which
would be a real disadvantage in the
situation but who the hell knows what
the White Walkers have up their sleeves
even though I don't want it to be
possible I can think of several ways it
could be possible so let's just agree
yes yes the night king could kill a
dragon in the same way we'll have to
agree that if he can kill a dragon he
can raise a dragon to be a white as well
of course this makes for some plot holes
about why they only attacked hardhome
with dead people whites but we all know
how things go with CGI and like I said
it doesn't always make logical sense
everything that happens in the show so
yeah it is possible that he could raise
and ride a dragon that he turned into a
white part of the reason this is such a
difficult thing to wrap my head around
is because it's a theory that's been
around
as long as I can remember and it just
never stood out to me as being one of
the good ones in the current version of
the theory related to the leak I hear
people mentioning that the night King
gets a dragon to even things up that
doesn't seem necessary to me if the
White Walkers are as big as a threat as
we've been told we're led to believe
throughout the series and all the
related writings they don't need
anything the dragons even things up
they don't give humans the some sort of
huge advantage I'm not so arrogant to
think that I know what george RR martin
had planned for this and we don't have
much to go off here since the last two
books are out but everything always
seemed to be pointing to the dragon
having three heads not two heads and
then one on the other side the story
made me believe that this was necessary
and even with those dragons there would
still be a high price that would have to
be paid per the leak there will be a
battle Thoreau sir Berek or maybe both
die John almost dies and then the Sirian
dies seems like there would be plenty of
drama without the dragon dying Danny
comes to save them and then she's able
to turn the tide I mean it might make
for some good special effects and some
on-screen excitement but there's a lot
of other ways we could get to the night
king having a nice dragon if that was if
that was an important part of the story
I mean I don't want to ramble on about
this but what what purpose does it serve
so for every one that keeps asking when
I think about it I don't think it's
necessary and it sort of makes me wonder
about how different the end of the show
will be compared to the books when I say
different I think they're going to the
same place but I just don't I mean I
think this is a pretty far distance from
what's gonna happen in the books I could
be wrong a lot of people could be wrong
but it just doesn't seem likely
I won't completely hate on it since it
would probably still be fun to watch I'm
just not excited about and based on what
I just went over to be clear it's
definitely possible
this appointing when you've been super
into something you know you've been
reading watching and thinking about this
thing and it turns out differently than
what the consensus leading up to the end
was there are a lot more characters and
stories in the book so maybe some how
this works is a combination of things to
get to the same place at the end it's
hard to see but as
it would be to say that D and D are
incompetent and ruling everything that
hasn't really always been the case
they've done things I didn't like
and things that haven't made logical
sense but the show still is good at a
lot of things so freaking out like it
would be the end of the world is pretty
pointless to do I think the leak is
absolutely right no there's a lot of
stuff that's turning out to line up with
what's already out there though my view
is that some of the stuff just doesn't
add up
in that way it just goes to show how
leaks are not fun if it does turn out to
be a hundred percent right how has that
improved the experience of watching the
show for us I don't know about you guys
but I'm gonna wait until I see it to
believe it let me know in the comments
what you think do you think white ice
dragon adds to the story do you think if
it turns out to be true that the show is
in the middle of a huge nosedive what do
you think they could be merging from the
books that might turn out to make sense
for how things develop for season 8
please like the video if you enjoyed
watching it and subscribe to my channel
to keep up with the latest videos leave
a comment if there's anything you want
to talk to obviously I made this video
not because I wanted to but I did it
more of a QA based on the same question
getting asked over and over again so if
there's something you want to see a
video about just let me know I mention
the book giveaway in the beginning which
is open to all subscribers who leave a
comment when I reach 28 thousand
subscribers all pick one comment from
all the videos where I mentioned this
giveaway and send that person a copy of
the new illustrated 20th anniversary of
a game of Thrones
I'll put an Amazon link in the
description so you can go there and give
it a look if you haven't seen it yet
it's pretty awesome thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon